hey I'm scum Prez my name is Peter Pan -
Ken welcome back to parser machete Eddie
bites rashes coughing no they're clean
you know we're gonna need those weapons
back yeah she can totally see oh we
can't tell anything you'll get him back
once we've cleared all this [ __ ] watch
it girl you're in deep enough already
that's weird
I had my way I just stumped you over the
side see how well you swim with your
hands tied behind your back
I might talk to me Yomi that'll get me
listen to easy you're lucky she doesn't
seem like the most
you can't talk to this [ __ ] hey cut
that's exactly pink when spoken to
understand yes Oh you let's start with
you what's your name it's okay
you can tell me my name's me Sean
Randall
now that the pleasantries are behind us
let's talk about what you did we didn't
take anything from you shut your mouth
I'm talking to your cohorts
cohort
but we're not the only ones you've
stolen I didn't still ship from you then
you've got nothing to worry about
let's see here nice machete you handle
those walkers back there
how are you against something that can
actually fight back
plenty sharp untie me and I'll show you
Oh
oh yes you got to be comfortable getting
in close get messy you know every person
we find living they got something with
there was it for you mother father a
couple sisters maybe
oh now kids you how the [ __ ] can you
laugh at that oh man I wouldn't have
guessed that in a million years
so you
you got nothing left to lose no wonder
you're all stoic it [ __ ] you better back
the [ __ ] off
whoo sounds like I hit a nerve
don't feel bad I'm a lot like where do I
recognize him from shame in that is he
has special actor special actor I don't
know why special oh that's dope
that you got a good look last time you
were here too busy stealing from us to
appreciate our little community
bet you never gave them a second thought
folks you [ __ ] over it wasn't us
what was that we haven't been here
before save it for normal I swear I
recognize her someone's sister she's the
one in charge Oh God
she'll be just she's gonna be super nice
first but she's actually gonna be super
fierce and just slay know this cut type
of characters
I hope she's different I hope I'm wrong
was he wearing panties on his face and
Lomb wearing panties on my face
Zachary thank God
are they making out you hurt I'm fine
bonus [ __ ] I'm fine there
I found your missing medicine Thanks
I'll uh get this back to the sick bay
I'd recognize him too your jobs not done
yet
come on Randall what's all this
I hoped I'd never see you again Samantha
Norma I'm not a word not from you
found them on the ferry along with this
that one there shown she's the one to
watch out for
that true you dangerous
she'll believe me I've never been wrong
about something like this I'm dangerous
when I need aren't we all
though dangerous isn't so bad anymore
you survive if you're dangerous I can
respect that
randl escort these ladies to the
storeroom whoo that's not fancy
comfortable for the other two oh that's
my brother come on
you got this under control
Sam Greg you'll be okay get moving
it's very fallout to this city like
actually made the place nice and [ __ ]
it's pretty cool I like it thumbs up I'm
interesting to see where it's going
usually they're Walking Dead games they
start off kind of slow but then you get
so into it because you get so invested
in all the characters that's that that's
how I feel I mean at least season 2 I
remember I thought was kind of weird in
the beginning this is interesting but
right now it's a bit slow I would say
what a satisfying sound no you worry
about him what about Greg looks a bit
empty doesn't like something's missing
luckily my sister's good at getting
answers she'll find out what you did
with the rest of it and if she doesn't
the two of us are gonna have ourselves a
talk I'm not gonna let you do this keep
an eye on her she's got a neck start on
it very convincing I'm not gonna let you
get anyway what you think goes down and
I'm blaming you and you don't want that
nothing's gonna happen down here see
that it doesn't see
that's Spanish for you I'd say make
yourself comfortable but that's probably
not gonna happen
oh [ __ ]
Oh uncomfortable you're gonna hurt Greg
these people
you don't know what they're capable of
will you be quiet so I can think fine
you go right ahead should have never
involved my brother in this sin attend
now um who knows what they're gonna do
to him why would they hurt Greg if the
two of you didn't do anything wrong
because these are not good people
this is my fault
so sorry I are you probably asleep just
trying to protect my family that that's
all I never thought they'd go back to
the ferry I didn't know what the hell is
going on here I just wanted to use the
radio to reach people I never expected
that Randal will show up they're not
after ties are too tight you see
anything we can cut him with
anything with a sharp edge
No
uh yeah awkward hmm okay with someone
really loves their cigs same brand that
was in the duffel uh this used to be
full how should I know
seriously
mob Jack it's the name of the ferry
these must have come from there really
well we looked everywhere
let's talk to I guess hey Sam
are you looking yes I find something
seriously what have I missed
Oh one of the mob Jack's first aid kits
this is why there was nothing left on
that ferry
it's all here like a boy is it soothing
oh oh no she's gone schizo Robo Chompy
mr. Grimm prefer
once you gone schizo you can't go on go
what's going on
this is freaking me out just leave me
alone
I didn't mean to pry
see we picked the right one well I'm
glad we did that
come on if you want to get out of this I
need you to tell me the truth
you saw those bodies back at the ferry
that was another group we trade it with
them sometimes
Randall killed them all everyone even
the kids geez came with his whole crew
and he just murdered them son of a [ __ ]
Norma told him to she must have
and they took what was left that's why
this stuff is here that's what they do
they think they own everything on the
water whatever they find they take and
if you put up a fight
oh you know what happens
they just I saw what Rendell did now do
you get it
if there's anyone out there that you
care about don't tell these people a fig
someone's coming back the pipes loose
just more I can get free changing wait
we have to get out of here are you with
me this is our chance whoever comes
through that door we jump them we can do
this together it's now or never
The Times not right I'll get us out of
here but not like this just wait and
follow my lead okay I'm trusting you
hey we didn't do anything a promise
honestly right down here here I was
ready for a fight
nice work get together we did a good job
which is good because Norma wants to
talk to you nothing but a funny word
come on I promise about Greg
well that's what normal wants to talk to
you about
how can she be so fat Michelle
that's a great name no Emma I always
wanted to be a Veronica or Gwendolyn
when I was a girl but I've made my peace
with it I suppose you're lucky though
you got a name people remember your
canon of young damn that's good I'm not
gonna talk too strong not one for small
talk are you
yeah she's bullshitting I'm sorry about
all this but I just want to talk that's
all
then you mind taking these off sure once
I get to know you better
I know you're angry but try to consider
things from my perspective everything
points to you stealing from me from my
people
that puts you and I on opposite sides of
the fence that's not how you see it
enlighten me
help me understand Paul goes well I'd be
happy to remove him for you you want to
know me let's talk that's what I like to
hear you're gonna help me get to the
bottom of things you do that and you get
to go home gone
consider it a peace offering there you
go
so tell me you and Samantha how long you
all been together I haven't seen you
before but then you might have been
lying though we're not together
I don't know these kids so you say and
what brought you to that fairy I feel
like we should just be on top of the
strange you just stumble on it out there
in the middle of the water it's just a
little difficult to wrap my head around
Pete and I picked up a signal on the
shortwave it was coming from the ferry
is a curry yeah get Jani to take a crew
on down to the mob jack see if anyone
else picked up on this signal bring
anyone they find back here III think
it's a property need help don't take
care of them so how about your group are
there others I need to know who's with
you can't act on incomplete information
there's nobody else
that's what she said right that's
interesting
I know how this whole thing must look to
you I get it
but there's more to this than you
realize whether you're with him or not
there's something you should know about
Samantha
that girl is a natural-born liar she's
good
I'll bet she laid it on thick for you
said it was all her fault she's sorry
and won't you please help her escape
big bad Norma am I getting warm wouldn't
be the first time she fed that line to
somebody you almost believed it you
haven't exactly proven her own you're
the one who grabbed us locked us up for
good reason she's lied to us before
stolen from us before you can see why I
might be just a tad frustrated I mean I
let her go no constant yeah
I'm frustrated me too I'm glad to hear
you say that
not a lot of good people left I'm afraid
there's a fine line between being
generous and being taken advantage of
everyone deserves a second chance I
believe that but never a third
most people will take advantage if you
let him did you give a second chance to
Rasheed and Vanessa who Rasheed and
Vanessa never heard of them but if they
showed up here sure they get their
chances I'm trying to protect these
people that's what we do here I bring
folks in see that they're fed clothed
looked after what about what you take
from them
the salvage we need the same things
anybody does we pool our resources we
survive I'm not telling you anything you
don't know
another more beating around the bush
where's the rest of it what'd you say
you weren't with those kids but Randle
caught you with them you had this but
there's still much more missing so where
is the rest of it up your ass [ __ ] an
ammunition it's probably on the ferry
mm-hmm Zachary and cam already did a
sweep at the ferry and they didn't find
a thing
where is it I told you bringing the kid
what what are you doing oh my god
what are we gonna do here's how this is
gonna work I know he's not gonna talk to
me his sister's probably filled his head
with all kinds of stories so you'll be
asking the questions like going me
goddamn she's mad I guess being a pain
in the ass runs in the family
Greg is it we're just gonna do a little
fat chicken Greg see if your story
squares up there's no way I'm talking to
you after what your brother's done
[ __ ] Rendell [ __ ] you you want another
one Randall come on
Michonne mind asking Greg what I asked
you go on now ask him I'm not doing
anything for you
well if that's how you feel yeah oh my
god
how long you two been running around
together yeah yeah a long time
we're old family friends hmm that's not
how Michonne told it she said you
weren't even together someone's full of
[ __ ]
you're just scared we'd be the kids a
liar oh hey okay
let's try again Michonne the one about
your people you remember don't you
ask him yourself
you're starting to piss me off oh [ __ ]
we had taken a lot of hits here that
wouldn't hurt a little
are there more you
there are two sir there's more of us
lots more well-armed - well that's
disappointing she said it was just you
four is he down Randall no please I'll
tell you whatever you want you don't
need to use that she's right
randal think you made your point
kid a towel Zachary get a towel okay
it's just a kid I'm a pity party when
we're done get the [ __ ] towel clean
up his [ __ ] urine he lying again try
to be kind try to extend my goddamn
hospitality
go [ __ ] yourself
oh thanks
god damn it for [ __ ] sake Randal Norma
please okay this isn't working
you're not gonna get what you want this
way you [ __ ] suggest a pat on the head
and a lolly he's got a point
Randall you took it too far like you
always do people need a firm hand you're
not gonna get him in line by being soft
now being smart isn't the same as being
soft Randall we're not gonna get what we
need your way Zachary and I will figure
this out you go below and get the other
pillow you make quite the pair Elias hmm
this world just depresses the hell out
of me
Zachary a word in private I wonder if
you could ever fully recover a cure he
asking me seriously what do you think
thank you suck at telling telling it
right stuff or is it gonna get worse
maybe they'd stop if you gave them what
they want what if I had it no matter how
many times I say it no one believes me I
can't believe I pissed myself yeah
that's pretty bad
seriously my little brothers could see
me now I've never done that before
never sure
I'm not like that afraid I'm not gonna
tell anyone what happened here
appreciate it
I'm pretty sure the smells gonna give it
away I knew about the rotters I mean I
fought them before killed them it's bad
but people are worse aren't they I
didn't know is this bad they know what
they're doing not everyone is like these
people I've met others folks who don't
kill unless they have to
I wish they were here I don't know
thing is is I I say that about people
but people family they're the only
reason to live what if you don't even
have that
I left them behind my daughter's I
didn't know
you lie to yourself to live so you keep
going but when you stop
Michonne
what did they do to you we just asked
questions at a party
Sam I haven't seen her [ __ ]
are we playing this yeah shown how are
we playing awkward I'm relieved
no matter what they're gonna hurt you
that's the least helpful advice I've
ever heard take care of this
come on
Zachry
I just have a few questions a few
questions I I'm really tired I think
I'll end this episode there it's really
late I just really wanted to play more
okay well thank you for watching another
episode go ahead and click on another
one and I'll see you Bruce they're
probably more well rested
thank you watching bad